depuis septembre 2020 le musée de la
ville de saint quentin en yvelines
propose d'éviter des vidéos du
patrimoine de l'agglomération
ces vidéos sont disponibles sur le site
de saint quentin en yvelines rue blick
rubrique culture en ligne mais aussi sur
leur chaîne youtube celle de sky et le
site internet du musée de la ville s'il
ya 400 go bonsoir bonsoir
donc c'est bien a expliqué nous quels
sont le genre de vidéos proposées hier
trois différentes thématiques existe ce
sont d'ailleurs les trois champs d'étude
du musée de la ville de saint quentin en
yvelines
d'abord patrimoine et territoires une
série qui présente le patrimoine saint
quentinois l'art à l'air libre autour
des oeuvres d'art dans l'espace public
et la minute design qui présente les
collections de design et mode de vie du
musée de la ville une fois par mois les
trois vidéos sont publiés est-ce que
vous avez un exemple à nous donner
justement
oui pour la série au patrimoine et
territoires justement de nombreuses
vidéos ont été tournées dans saint
quentin en yvelines comme par exemple le
quartier des prés à montigny le
bretonneux le quartier de champ fleuri à
voisins le bretonneux ou encore le
quartier 17 mar à elancourt regardez
donc la vidéo suivie de la réaction de
la responsable de l'action culturelle de
la ville du musée de la ville bienvenue
au quartier 17 mar à elancourt il s'agit
du premier quartier à avoir été
construite lors de l' aventure ville
nouvelle de saint quentin en yvelines
il a été inauguré en 1975 en octobre
c'est par la fête est inauguré le centre
des chefs marc elle nous permet de
montrer aussi des images d'archivés la
documentation qu'on a au sein des
collections de musées qu'on n'a pas
toujours l'occasion de montrer en
général donc les saint quentinois
connaissent le musée de la ville soit
pour l'aspect collection ou soit pour la
proche patrimoine mais finalement très
rarement sur le volet arts publics
oui et donc le musée de la ville a voulu
mettre en avant ce dernier volet la
passerelle de la gare de saint quentin
en yvelines le pont de grateloup ou
encore la perspective de marta pan sont
des oeuvres majeures de l'agglomération
ça permet de mettre vraiment en avant
des heures qu'on ne voit pas forcément
et d'inciter les gens à aller les voir
au détour d'une promenade et à découvrir
ses richesses là et donc qu'elles seront
célia les prochaines vidéos à découvrir
à la fin de la semaine trois nouvelles
vidéos seront proposés pour les
collections du musée ce sera sur les
essoreuse à salade
du côté de l'art à l'air libre vous donc
vous découvrirez une vidéo sur la grande
girouette une oeuvre dans le quartier
des soldats à guyancourt et enfin pour
la partie au patrimoine et territoires
ce sera sur le quartier de la et
bergeries aviles preuve
merci célia gâte son goût d'avoir été
avec nous journalistes pour tv 78